ready
sorry yeah than you well good evening
and welcome members officers and those
members of the public here at the
meeting and those joining us
vir item one on the agenda is apologies
for
yes chair councelor Pennington councelor
cot hunin councelor Thomas and councelor
Wht item two on the agenda is to agree
the minutes first of all of the fourth
of
September run through those page at a
time on page
five six
8or hes sorry yeah on page six of top
public contributions um Mr L spoke about
concerns regarding res residential
aution it will be clear B does that
relate to car
paring please not very
clear sorry which one is it can just
repeat that 167 second paragraph
concerns regarding residential kind
options does that relate to car
par does yes it does yes it does could
it be made a bit clearer just add
car yes I'm sure
that's I was on page eight so page
nine
11 and
second all in favor please
[Music]
show and again
and
abstentions numbers add
up excellent thank
you can you hear me
this I'm going to get up
clst okay the second set of minutes is
the extraordinary meeting on the 2nd of
October P
[Music]
17 and
18 to propose that
yeah
[Music]
so range anding was it yeah all in favor
please
show
again and
extensions okay thank
you okay moving on to item three on the
agenda the action list which is on page
19 one item was listed which challeng
the planning manager has confirmed the
letter was being worked
on be said on I don't think so moving on
then to item four cont public
contributions there are no public
contributions
recorded item five Declarations of
Interest members I know you all know the
story there you declare anything that
feel is appropriate item six agreement
of the agenda items part one and two
there are no part two
minutes item seven consider
correspondence vot forward by the chair
I personally haven't got anything just
chair if you wanted to
speak thank you chair I'd just like to
bring you up to speed a little bit on
the 11 up partnership um I've done it in
the form of bullet points um because I I
do stand off of points sometimes so I'll
go through the part um the thing
basically can can you just K that mic
down he's a bit closer to you then right
okay is that better we got to be right
up close to it
apparently I don't know right okay geter
without actually EA it right okay I'll
deliver it as bullet points and I can
have a few problems from the way as you
know um I want to give a members a
briefing on the update of the meeting I
had with 11 up minister or we had um 11
up Minister Jacob young MP with our own
MP and the chief act last Wednesday
afternoon October the 25th right the
members already know our previous
schedule meeting had been cancelled
which is why the up toate is within
urgent matters rather than report on the
agenda a more detailed report will be
prepared for the next full council
meeting in
December this was the first meeting of
the Le up with the Le up Minister since
Toge was as an area designated to work
in partnership with the government on
this policy initiative which has been
given to 19 other areas in addition to
torage and with a 400 million pound
allocated to to this area of work this
wasn't a formal start of the leveling up
partnership the minister made it quite
clear that that will commence in line
with the time table provided previously
to TDC which is March 24
and there will be no opportunity to
bring It Forward from that dat so um
that's that is what the rules are that's
what we would have to comply with the
process following the official launch in
March 24 will involve a number of
officials from the Lup the 11
partnership team undertaken a deep dive
at T analyzing data and information
about TDC and considering the form and
form
format of interventions that would level
up
PBC the L team leveling up partnership
will also be meeting and discussing with
key stakeholders from various sectors
and
organization I.E businesses agriculture
education and other others to understand
from The Wider perspective views with
what will level up
PDC in advance of this phase the L our
officers team will be with the L our
officers will be colting data evidence
and information and constructing a TGC
page story around what makes torage what
it is which is um and that would include
the good and the challenges what the
vision is for the area and that is
important that we have a an end vision
of where we're going not just a wish
list on the way and um and in order to
make TGC even better um great place to
live work and visit our officers will
also consolidate with other the other
Strate strategic base documents that
pull together and we will be work to
shape in TDC such as with Northern Devon
economic strategy and our own strategy
that we've been putting together
recently as a
council in terms of more specific
projects development phases the minister
made it clear that any specific projects
must be data and clearly evidence the
impact of improving the specific levels
of the matrixes that put TDC in this
position in the first place I.E the mvq
level
three uh the low number we have health
and life expectancy medium gross weekly
pay and gva per hour work
this is not an opportunity to produce a
wish list of projects as it will need to
be properly evidence how they achieve
fundamental changes in the challenges
faced by our residents and our community
this is a significant amount of work
that needs to be done over the coming
months and Beyond if TDC it to grasp
what might be a once in a generation
opportunity the council needs to
concentrate on this while also
maintaining focus on delivering our
other major projects the operational
services and the appid door Innovation
Center as mentioned earlier now that the
process has started to take shape we
will getting a much clearer picture of
understanding and of that I will bring
more details to the next full council
meeting so what I can say is that I felt
we had a very warm receptive meeting um
but it was made very clear the rules
that I've just laid out to you um how it
will be it won't necess necessarily be
how some people wish it would be but it
will be the starting date will not be
till next march when it will be launched
um we will encouraged in so much as the
money available and when it might start
becoming available but as it's been made
clear to us it will be based on data
evidence and the end goal of a vision of
to and better future for our residents
within college so on that point I just
thank you for listening to me I hope it
makes sense it is a great opportunity
our officers have been having an
enormous amount of work to do and the
one thing I would say is that we need to
consider that as members and how we go
forward to lose so on this amount of
money would be criminal if our officers
are tied up with other stuff so I I'm
asking you as leader we
consider that we look at the vision um
and we've got various things doing that
we have the economic strategy we have a
skills board we have Dev Northern
Futures we have a whole and they were
quite interested in the dev Norland
Futures which is basically a sort of a
pattern which we're doing ourselves with
North Dev and petrol it's a bit of a
pattern of how the leveling up um board
will look forward using the experts that
we have available um so it won't be just
toage there will be a lot of work in
getting evidence from other people the
board will consist of I said quite a lot
of outside experts that will be looking
it whether what we're putting forward
will actually make a solid contribution
to the Future college so I'm hoping that
we will be able to bring forward more
details at the moment you know as much
as I do and I think that's the right way
we do it which is why I've asked with
Chief ex to bring this forward tonight
um because by the time we get to it in
December hopefully we will have more
information and you might have more
questions when we do adress it again
thank you very much for
listen thank you counc
James before we move on to the next item
gentlemen and back member of the public
got some seating over here sir if You'
like to come and join us just over the
other side of the
[Music]
room okay the next item on the agenda
agenda item eight is a presentation from
local artist Sandy Bryant so if you like
to come up to the stand standy you can
uh 10 minutes will start with the time
when she
starts I say
10es got a little bit of anyway 9 and a
half will be
fine thank
you well it's it's can I ask you to
speak into the
microphone um it's an honor to be a to
speak to you today thank you so much for
inviting me um
and I'd like to thank the Reverend um
Ian RIT and the Reverend John Koso for
coming along and offering their moral
support to the project that I'm about
about to offer you a very
exciting opportunity to acquire
something which I think will tick a lot
of boxes for you um if you don't know me
I my name is Sandy Brown I am an artist
in clay in color I live in applore and I
um I've been I use Devon clay I've been
working in clay for over 50 years I have
been described thus Sandy Brown is
internationally known as an influential
figure in European and World
Ceramics Gabby dial a writer on ceramics
in Germany wrote this in the
international Ceramics magazine called
keramic
today it is hard to imagine the Europe
European ceramic scene without her she
is famous for her spontaneous passionate
use of clay and
colors Sandy Brown's catalytic
liberating influence on European
Ceramics must not be
underestimated I have been invited to
have solo exhibitions of my work in the
USA in Australia Germany and South
Africa and China I have been invited to
present at conferences worldwide in
Ceramics conference over 46 museums
worldwide have bought examples of my
work to hold in their permanent
collections so an example of my work
this is what I'm known for this is one
image of my work I'm known for being one
of the pioneers and using um color
colorful Blazers in contemporary
Ceramics it's one of the things I was
known for initially so thank you we have
the next image and this is an example of
a a throne a chair that I made that is
now in the colle permanent collection of
the Frankford Museum of Applied Arts
they bought it from a solo exhibition I
have I had in Germany a few years ago
next please and this is an example of a
square flatter of mine which is in the
permanent collection of the Victorian
Albert Museum in London
here and this is a ceramic platter which
was sold from an exhibition in um in in
Germany a few years ago it gives you an
idea of what I one of the things I do
next image um I also do large scale
sculptures this is on the continent of
Europe in in a in a Architects
collection
yeah and this is in um this was in
rufford um ruined Abby at rufford in
Nottingham Shire
and this is in China I was invited I was
one of 10 British artists selected to
represent Britain in a big International
Conference in China and to make some new
work for a brand new Museum in China and
this is the work that they chose to stay
there um um which is now in their
permanent
collection and this is in a a a private
elction this is a sculpture that I was
commissioned by St a to make for its
Town Center last year it is uh um s osel
is the China clay Hub of the UK and the
world and they wanted to celebrate their
clay culture so I made an Earth goddess
she is in fact the tallest tallest
ceramic sculpture in the world and has
been credited with um enhancing an
increasing visitor numbers to C host and
increasing uh tourist traffic and
visitors and business
generally thank
you and this is the project that I'm I'm
here to to talk about with you this is
Temple This was um commissioned uh
initially um for a temporary exhibition
by SES for a temporary Exhibition at
Chatsworth house an exhibition of
contemporary Monumental sculpture and I
was the only Ceramics person invited
alongside Henry Moore Barbara heor
Anthony goury all the biggest names in
British ceramics that there have ever
been and uh so it is a
temple
next it
is yeah next
oh yes no Ian love it Ian Ian look
there's your Ian yes the Reverend Ian
love it actually is responsible he's
probably the only Vicor who did the
Ceramics degree and he responsible for
the gold leaf at the top of the pineal
at the top of the temple so thank you
for doing
that um yes so and this is inside the
Temple it is a space it is um it has a
serious intent it's a space for
contemporary ritual and ceremony and
reflection and so inside uh all all of
the all of the tiles were handmade in
appor in my studio and I made and
painted them all and there the seats
inside the square cubes the seats the
round ball is an object of
contemplation and you will see that um
um one of the ways I my work has also
grown out of although you may not
realize it to look at has actually grown
out of the North Dev traditional
Ceramics earwar tradition of using
colored slips and colored Clays over
each other this is one of my favorite
tools it's a tool which you have to
squirt one color over another color it's
a traditional North de tool for a slip
trainer a Potter tool and North Devon
traditional Ceramics using um in the
Harvest jugs which are in the in the
Burton art gallery some of the best
Ceramics made in the UK the best
traditional Ceramics were made here the
bitterford Harvest jugs are the best
Ceramics and traditional Ceramics made
in the UK they're full of life and I was
inspired by them as a as a child it was
the first Galler that I ever came
to
um so yes so I've been called cated my
way of using Color freely and freshly
inside the temple and outside thank
you and this is inside the temple
looking up into the Dome there are
skylights in the temple there's colored
glass in the Skylight made by um a um a
colleague of mine who is a well-known GL
artist he was a direct he was here at
dartington glass for many years he's now
director of salviati glass in Venice he
teaches at the Royal College of Art and
he developed a completely new method of
making of fusing two colors of glass
together to make the colored roof tiles
that allow the colored glass panels to
allow the colored light to come into the
temple inside and it's
[Music]
beautiful um yeah so uh
yeah Ste painting this is how it looks
before it goes in the kill the colors
look completely different before they go
in the K it's geological
chemistry making the
glazes and so this is the infrastructure
of the temple it has a wooden
infrastructure and the colored tiles are
all screwed onto the onto the so it's
very stable it's as strong and as
weatherproof as any house will be in
fact if not more so because they're all
glazed I mean roof tiles house roof
tiles aren't glazed bricks aren't glazed
but these are so they're highly
weatherproof at chapsworth it was
outside for 3 years in heavy weather and
storm and it's
fun so that gives you an idea of the um
yes so there we are that is Temple and
um Richard Corp who is um a Time Times
art critic describes Temple as an
influential work that rise conventional
Notions of sculpture or architecture its
commanding presence resembling an
Exquisite building with El flamboyant
columns and arches immediately
captivates the Discerning Eye it is a
state CR
sanctuary and as more and more
increasingly um fewer and fewer of us
are the our culture is the number of
Christians is is declining the number of
Christians marriages that there were a
few years ago in Devon were where there
were
4,500
weddings um of which only one quarter of
which only
1,500 were religious ceremonies the
other three quarters were not religious
ceremonies and so increasing and
memorials um um after crematoriums after
if you are non if you are not religious
where do you have your your sacred
ceremonies and rituals we don't have
place places for those people to to have
their cere ceremonies in a place which
is spiritually uplifting this is a
unique work of art there is nothing like
this anywhere in the world bord could be
leading the way in showing I actually
think that all district councils
Nationwide should have a space like this
to offer to uh people of non non-
denominated people who wish to have
ceremonies and rituals um you provide
registry off you provide prator we need
to provide non-denominational spaces
which are spiritually uplifting for
rituals like this otherwise our culture
and our heritage is in danger of
declining and
dying
uh Jeremy Vine the BBC broadcaster big
fan of my work he's made a he's made a F
film of of Temple and he's placed it
um
uh yes so um there we go I think that's
thank you s that's that's nearly 15
minutes and I just wanted you know for
give a few minutes for members to ask
any questions so
um so what's what's the actual plan here
then is it you say for hor assistant
Council to acquire it I mean is it it
obviously comes with cost it it does yes
it does it's not a gift no unfortunately
it can't be there what um you say in in
Victoria Park
um any particular place in there where
you think it would be
cited my my my own personal reservation
is how durable it would be not the
weather I'm not concerned about that but
um you know what it's like when you put
a building up in a lot of public places
nowadays I would hate to see the
aftermath of of anything happening to
that one um you know after
some some damage you know some Hooligans
or whatever you know any yes it would it
would need to it would need to be
protected and so my suggestion is is
that it could have um some very tall
railings around it right right opposite
my house I live right opposite the
Richmond dock in appor and there's some
uh uh large tall railings around there
Richmond do has been absolutely safe and
secure and the railings the Richmond dot
railings are black but I mean the
railings around the temple could be tall
they could be pale blue to to coordin
basically it would be fenced off then
until such a time as it's opened up for
anyone to actually visit it the public
wouldn't be able to just walk in and
walk out no exactly exactly yes and it
could be it could be um done you know if
the Burton art gallery were sort of um
interested in in sort of um um
incorporating it could be used as an
extra space for the Burton art gallery
that was one suggestion one of the
people at the Burton made and so um you
know that's another way of um making use
of it it could make money for torage as
well by renting it out for weddings and
memorials any anyone else got any
questions you haven't mentioned costs um
what are we talking about in the way of
you know funding for this or it's not
going to be donated free of charge to us
is it no unfortunately not for a period
of time maybe until we know whether or
not we can adopt it and keep it or pay
for it over a certain time could you
mention something about costs thank you
well you know it was uh when it was
exhibited at chatworth it was
independently valued by two Arts uh
professionals uh unknown to each other
unknown to each other they independently
valued it at 1 million each they both
said that they both said that
um somebody came into the my studio last
week because it's now installed in my
studio so you could come along and see
it I invite you all to my studio in
appor to come and see it you can go
inside and you know Peter Christie has
been and a few others have been and
Peter hes and I'd be very happy to show
you um uh so uh and and somebody who
came last week this art Art Expert who's
well known in the art dealing work he he
valued it at two million actually now
I'm not asking anything like that I'm
asking all I need to do is cover my cost
it's cost me a lot of money to make it
and to to provide everything so I'm
asking for 350,000 for the temple and
then there would be the cut of the
railings which I would you know and I
would I would do as much as I could to
help to make it possible I would
certainly be willing to involve young
people in the in the in the in the
process I would be willing to invite
schools and do talks in the temple and
and and teach them about the culture
that we have here as well as the the
possible rituals that there are and my
my experience is that young people
really get Contemporary Art and and it
makes them feel proud of the place
they're
from thank you Sandy for that lovely
presentation I'm obviously we can't make
the decision here tonight so it'll be
referred to the relevant uh committee to
discuss them back to full council with
some kind
of some kind of recommendation I would
imagine um there's one other thing I
would say about the funding is that um I
don't know you know there's you're
talking about the leveling up fund
earlier there's also I was looking at um
the um criteria for the Heritage Lottery
fund and because this is a a project
that actually seeks to preserve our
cultural heritage of rituals and
ceremonies um that is a posibility and
also just one other thing I the reason
that the Reverend Ian L and the Reverend
John caroso are both here in support of
this project is they would very much
like to be celebrants and to perform
rituals inside the temple when it's
established and part of life
here thank you very much thank you thank
you that's it thank you very much thank
you thank you for your attention thank
you very
much okay moving on then to uh item nine
housing assistance policy for better
care fund ages 20 to
84 bber a presentation thank you thank
you
CH even counselors unfortunately I don't
have any Beau pictures for mine um so
this is a review and update of the
council's housing assistant policy for
the better care fund um council is
obliged the fund excuse me mandat
disable fertilities
grants um in line with the housing
grants construction and regeneration act
1996 um the grants provide for
adaptations to allow people to stay
independent in their
home so the grants are maximum £30,000
and that is centrally set by government
the council receives annual ring fence
funding from the better care fund for
this purpose um and a summary of the
budget and spend is contained um in your
notes from page
21 um in addition to the disabled
facilities Grant the mandatory Grant the
council can provide discretionary
assistance which is allowed by the
regulatory reform housing assistance
order
2002 uh in order to offer the
discretionary assistance the council is
required to adopt and publish a policy
which is this this
policy um any discretionary assistance
um funded by the best care fund needs to
work towards the de bed care fund
priorities and these are outlined in
section two of the policy on page 34 of
your
notes um we target um areas by directing
funding and extending the disabled
facilities Grant to a wider group um by
providing topup funding to ensure that
we can um undertake larger adaptations
where needed and to offer grant funding
and low cost loans for Home Improvements
um for
homeowners
so this is just an update to the
existing policy the summary of the
assistant being offered and the policy
changes is contained in your notes on
pages 23 and 24 councelor hackit the
lead member has been consulted and is
happy to support this
policy and we're seeking adoption by the
council uh for the revised policy thank
you very much any
questions yes it the beginning of this
report it's already been approved it
says on page
25 has been approved already I think
last away
it
see on the minutes but already approved
for introduction on
December why it now sorry it sorry I put
I put that in there as the draft for
this evening in the anticipation of so
apologies that's my my fault with
miscommunication so that was all blanked
out with so I just put it as today's
date apologies for that
yeah um just a matter on the the figures
on page 21 um the budget and the spend
the spend is relatedly consistently and
underspent is that
because applications were less than
expected or is that and what happens to
the money so good question the um left
over money we have an agreement so the
better care fund is uh allocated to
Devon County Council locally and Deon
County then in agreement with the
districts distribute the better care
fund money in accordance with formula
they worked out which looks at the
previous year spend so it looks at the
last three spend usually so any
underspend what we tend to do is we tend
to keep any underspend and then that
will be taken into account in the next
um formula when they allocate the funds
so if you note the next year's money is
always quite High even though our our um
allocation from government our actual
allocation is is never really more than
a million but we always end up with more
than a million in budget because we
carry that over
effectively okay counc Bron you want ask
a question thank you chair yes so for
the question of the finances um is there
something wrong with our policy or
communication that we have any
understand understand we should not have
any understanding bearing in mind the
demographic of our area the elderly
population I mean we had a scheme many
years ago I can recall you know our
budget used to be gone by about six
months into the financial year you know
people were queing up for it and it went
so we should not never ever have a
unpend on this short this so is there
some something wrong with our
Communications with the people agencies
and all rest of it who who could get
access to this or why is that yeah sorry
and you asked about the underspend as
well apologies so uh the underspend we
rely on referrals from occupational
therapists at Deon County Council so any
disabled facilities grant that we offer
has to be ACC company or starts with a
referral from occupational thus um and
we have very little influence over how
many referrals we receed so what we can
do and what we have done in the past is
we go out to GP surgeries for example
and raise awareness of this um I was
just discussing today in fact potential
of putting some marketing for this into
um like council tax mailers things like
that try and raise awareness so you're
right to say it um but this is another
part of the discretionary funding in the
policy is we need to Target that
discretionary funding so that again we
don't get any understand we're spending
our allocation on the things that matter
to us so this has been drafted with
those priorities in mind to try and
Target this funding so that we don't get
any underspend but it's about fine
tuning it really and making sure that
every year when we run is just looking
at where that you know where where we
could potentially spend a bit more
against some of our
priorities can I just come back chair on
that yes may start with Sur
they all have these sort of rolling
screens now where they're sitting there
waiting various topics come up on there
perhaps we could slot into those so that
people do it because it does mention
their agents as well that's another one
where perhaps some of the state agents
there you know people are buying the D
siid or whatever they can have adaptions
and all that type of thing so you know
there is a potential there I think to
getting out into the public more than we
doing
in yeah I've got a few speakers but can
just bring sty JW in second thing to
consider is this is means tested as well
so you it depending upon your income and
your disposable assets um you might not
qualify um the the other difficulty um
with it is if you qualify for a
mandatory DFG we have to provide that so
we've got always got a balancing act
with these budgets because if we spend
all of our allocation and then somebody
applies for a DFG under the mandatory
criteria we're obliged to to fund that
so we especially with Council budgets
are at the moment we've got to be really
careful about about dragging it out so
it's not free money to everybody there
are criteria and it is usually a means
tested
criteria first and then go cig C side
after just um back to what you're say
about you've got to keep something in
reserve I mean you're talking about sort
of the old
300,000 UND spend which if the maximum
Grant is 30,000 is an awful lot of
emergency you're keeping in reserves and
can I ask how many people get turned
down that and what the reasons are for
doing that and surely and does it maybe
not understanding it properly for which
I apologize but when you say excuse me
there's an UND spend and then judges
that that next year do they say you
didn't that you had that in reserve and
therefore what they give you like if you
had 300,000 that you didn't spend this
year does that mean next year's
allocation is like a million but you
only get 700,000 because you didn't
spend the
300,000 is see what I'm saying I see
what you're saying not not necessarily
is the answer to the last part they look
at Devon as a whole so we're putting as
Devon as a whole and um it's worth
probably stating at this point that the
majority of districts run and under
spend on their better care fund um it's
not unusual to run it an UND
spense that yeah sorry
just what's what's the benefit in
running band why not get the help out
there to the people that need it you
hear about people help all
time there's no benefit to running on
spend as such it's just that we if we
don't get the referrals we we can't we
can't spend the money that's you know so
are there a lot of applications that get
disqualifying
or you just not get the application not
huge numbers no we just don't get that
many applic I mean say when I say we
don't get that many applications we do
between 50 and 100 adaptations per year
of people's
properties so we do we do a lot of good
work hope coun Brenton's suggestion May
well increase that uptake and cre
next just kind of sort of follow on from
the BR actually I think it's the social
prescribers that you really need to to
be dealing with because they are the
people that deal war between between the
money of the social services and
Healthcare now it is the social
prescribers that deal with those people
that don't fit in to the normal boxes so
I would have thought that they would be
a priority really in in order to get
people's homes adapted so they can
maintain sorry before I get to you
question Branton I had hands up the back
Council hacket first I think wasn't name
Council no well I was going to come in
to move the
recommendation um
but if there I think we' in air
discussion but if anybody else wishes to
speak first yeah counc L first and then
councelor Brandon yeah perh I to declare
an interest because three months ago I
did have a stale fitted in my farmhouse
and I knew nothing about this Grant and
the company that I use for the daying
fron just said to me to apply for a
grant so I said no I know nothing about
it and they gave me the contact
information right fine um this is a very
broad range of Grant from all sorts of
things from topup Grants to ster grants
we Happ a lot and healthy homes surely
we're missing a trick here we need to up
upgrade our um expertise on this because
this surely will feed into the leveling
up application it may not be quite part
of the stries
thats the young ofing but on the other
hand additional evidence showing that we
have a population and we know we do who
live in substandard housing and who are
low income and who are not very healthy
in many cases will all add additions to
the application for our leveling up
funding and yet at the same time you
look at these statistics and it looks as
if there's no need or not that much need
for it well that's very contradictory
and it really doesn't help us with our
leveling up campaign so I really do
think we need to make much more effort
to get much better take up of all these
broad grants that definitely this
community needs far more than we
given right
C that's the last one then I'm going to
go to the V sorry I just
wonder one of my constituents um in
desperate need of appropriate housing
for um is living with her mother in
upstairs and downstairs not being able
to go upstairs anymore and there's a
real limit
on appropriate hous in Bungalows or
whatever available and you know the
meeting getting into a real price in
that situation for example would those
people would the council or the housing
person go to them and say Here's a grant
for £3,000 put a stairlift in so that
the pressure on you needing to move
house is taken away if they come off the
housing
list would that happen automatically and
if not why not so in circumstances such
as that um there's two things to
consider one they would need need an
occupational therapy referral from Devon
County so it wouldn't that's not up to
us would you advise them to get one yes
we would absolutely if we came into
contact with someone like that we'
absolutely do that do it is a means
tested Grant as Stacy said so we would
need to do a test of resources although
one of the things we have done in this
policy I should state to try and address
some of the underspend and make things
um a bit fairer cross board is to take
the first £10,000 of any contribution
out of play so the Poli states that we
will pay the first £10,000 of any
contribution so that should bring a few
more people into grant funding rather
than having to pay contribution good
been proposed by Council for the
seconding all in favor please show you
do this
person anous thank you very
much okay uh J item 10 is to receive the
report from head of legal governance
monitoring officer um this is the care
lever's discount
policy very good evening members so I
last presented this to PO Council on the
4th of September um when it was agreed
in principle um that torage would offer
an exemption to on their council tax for
care leevers in the Devon area and that
was subject to a full policy and further
detail coming forward and to full
Council which is is is what I'm
presenting tonight so I know there's
been various meetings ongoing um with
the Devon authorities with Devon
County um with the chief exec with the
section1 officers and revson Ben's
officers about how best to achieve this
um the predominent principle behind this
is to give care levers within the Devon
area um a cushion um when they leave
care um and a form of protection to kind
of ease them into um full-time life up
until the age of 25 so the proposal is
um that torage alongside other Devon
authorities Grant 100% exemption on
their council tax up until the age of
25 um where by thereafter that exemption
would no longer apply um the US e EST
way um for torage to achieve this is
through the council tax reduction scheme
and the exceptional hardship policy um
just by way of reference for the year
2324 um that total amount for care
levers within um the torage area would
amount to just over
8,000 um and tor's contribution to that
so what Tor would be funding would be
£650 um obviously Financial is going
forward I can't confirm um how many care
leevers will be in the the area um but
that's the proposal that we award 100%
exemption up until they
25 happy to take any questions you
moving this I'll second it all favor
please
show
much
item 11 adoption of the CCTV policy
Pages 103 to 100 what you so again
members this should be very very brief
it's just to introduce um a CCTV quality
for torage um that we can publish on our
website so that the public are clear
about where um torage have our CCTV
cameras our reasons for having
CCTV um how we use that data how we
process how we erase the data for
example and how the public can approach
us if they need requests from that
CCTV um so it gives our staff and the
public a clear policy by which we use
process delete and May in certain
instances release that data um usually
for crime and protection purposes um
again happy to take any questions
currently we don't have a policy in
place so I'm quite happy to move this
the second can I just add um could
members just if if we have other sites
or need to remove CCTV can they just
allow officers to do to do that because
sometimes we bring new CCTV online and
I'm aware that we've got our operational
Center coming forward so that will no
doubt need CCTV as well so would they
allow that um officers to make that
Amendment with addition or removal of
site should we need to I think that is
very important that officers have got
the freedom to be to do that rather than
coming back to committee each time
coun Smith do you want to speak just
like
second Okay C Bron I just want to ask
chair do we use facial identification
that because there's a lot of
controversy about it need
noine
thank okay been have been seconded so
all in favor please
show
CH okay item 12 cycle of committee
meetings Pages 113 115 and the chief
going
present CH I don't think there's any
need to prepare a presentation for you
is to schedule the committee meetings
for the next year
2425 um happy to answer any questions to
but it's just there for members to
approve
well I'll move that from the
chair c Harding second all in favor
please
show well thank you item 13 to answer
questions submitted under procedur rule
A9
and one question thank you very much
I've got the response to that which is
basically an amazing thing there's no
cost whatsoever even
though
himself motion
which that we actually have installed
here micro remember is that not going to
take place
now because that's why I was asking the
question um so there's not going to be
any cost at these installation microphon
up here then well clearly there's not
going to be any microphones in stalled
not 36 of them anyway what I can gather
right well I aware of that I just wanted
to know that um of course while I was
asking this question I also put in
another couple of questions and was told
I was not allowed to do that even though
standing officers do say and us the in
they use the indefinite article any
question they didn't it didn't say the
question definite article so clearly
that's open to interpretation that still
stands in in the stand that I just
looked at tonight that actually a
question does not imply only one
question so I think that's a bit of an
issue because I did have two more
important questions I wanted to ask and
they have been censored of this meeting
obviously I'll bring them up to the next
meeting and the one after that but the
point is the point I'm making is that
isn't it's thing it's an inde indefinite
article and that means it implies a
question it doesn't imply seven
questions one question and if it is only
one question it should be in the
standing orders so that there's no
confusion thank you thank you
counc okay moving on to item 14
petitions we don't have any petitions so
item 15
notices of motion we've got four notice
of motions and the first one of
chis thank you um got to start with an
apology to my fellow members of the
planning committee you have heard me go
on about this quite a few times um I've
got to the point where I've really lost
patience uh every planning application
we get whether it's huge Estates or very
small ones and Villages Southwest
water there are statutory consult uh
they come back has no objection and you
think oh that's all right then but of
course it isn't because we know there
are major problems uh with Southwest
water in terms of spills uh 2022 in
bford Riverbank there were 24
spills I'm sure our officers are very
aware of it uh quite often when I go
down R Bank the smell is quite poing um
butley in Northern 31
spills it added up if you add it up it
came to 17 days of
spills uh abish which is our main SE
treatment plant for the whole area for
ball and bford um had 144
spills now they aren't just around bord
Northern uh we're Gifford 17
that lasted a total of 45 days torington
25 spills an equivalent of 13 days all
these figures are on the online you can
look at them and it really annoys me
when you see Southwest B saying oh no we
have no objection to this why not
because every house that's connected up
has to pay Southwest water they are a
monopoly all right they'll take the
money but they don't seem to be doing
what they should be doing in tackling um
our infrastructure little bit of History
here uh I actually joined the council
many I became a councel many many years
ago because of the sewage embargo in
bidford now many of you won't remember
this but Southwest water could not
handle any more sewage from any new
houses so the government stepped in and
slapped a sewage embargo on bit which
said you cannot build any new houses and
that lasted the late 70s went on well
into the
80s and yet now you think wait a minute
has anything changed Southwest water
clearly cannot handle the sewage and yet
here we are being told no problems you
can pass that state this is why my
motion is before you today I'm asking
two things you can see what they are
firstly how can Southwest water justify
their very Bland statement that comes up
every time but secondly slightly
revolutionary one this because I did
suggest at the planning committee some
time ago that we shouldn't
vote through any newer States until
Southwest water can sort out the
problems unfortunately I can't see that
holding much water I can see Southwest
water challenging that and
winning however I would like the
government to look at removing Southwest
water from the list of saturated consult
are we going for an
independent view because if you look at
my last line there it says they would
look at new devel water
availability we've had a drought in this
area in summer all right we're now
having floods but Southwest world can't
seem to balance that at the moment
there's no new reservoirs online or
anything seage capacity we all know that
they can't handle sewage
capacity so my
is there in front of
you I would ask for a second and ask to
support thank you I'm happy to Second up
the chair Christian I don't suppose
there's many people here that's going to
argue against the sentiment of what you
just
say yeah can I just say I utterly agree
with C Chris he said it's so frustration
on plans committee but could we not um
ask for a representative of Southwest W
to come and talk either to the whole
Council or specifically to the plans
committee like we have with um highways
and Deon County Education authority to
see if we can get them to explain face
to face to us because I don't think
going out to outside bodies will perhaps
um better the situation because we would
have to pay them and we always argue
about expenses from
consules um but I would like a
representative of Southwest Walter to
come and speak to us before we issue all
the these other
bits very you please yes we have had
representative some Southwest water come
up before they won't tell us anything
you ask some figures you know what's the
carrying capacity of abish seage part
they won't tell and because they're now
a private company you can't even put in
a Freedom of Information
either appren first of all well I
totally agree with councelor Christie um
and councel lo over this you know this
is really long it's long been a long
time since needed to do this sort of
thing we should have done it years ago
there's a big big development going on
up Beyond Atlantic Village or is now
known um and there's clearly a great
need there for us to be really careful
and scrupulous about the reserve matters
for that particular development and it
involved loads of um drainage and sewage
require
and at the moment Southwest Waters
behavior is scandalous we all know that
they don't carry out their legal
responsibilities they're continually
breaking the law with their effluence
and overflows and it's no good councel
saying oh we you know let's see if we
can get them to speak to us believe me
the before when we had the Embargo the
seage Embargo and the problems we had
with trying to get a decent out SE
outlet and not put SE into into the
river Tes and they just prevaricate and
and fob you off with their um 1984 type
speed we really need to make sure that
we have an
independent
honest assessment of our sewage needs in
this area we need somebody with
integrity and who who doesn't speak out
of money alone the proper is there not
there sole motive for our community we
need somebody and some organization that
knows that the welfare of our people and
our rivers and our sea is just as
important as making
money yeah can and then councelor Bron
then we're going to
go yeah um I would fully support um
Council Chris's line um could I just
suggest though that at the risk of
inflicting uh some additional work on
planning staff that we do a a simple
exercise to extract from say over a
period of time the last three years or
Last Five Years on all applications of
say five units or greater we actually
extract the um the response consultation
response from Southwest water uh because
I think that actually we actually need
to be able to prove to other people that
the response is actually uh the same
template coming each time and all it
does it tells you they've got no problem
and that as long as you join their main
with a smaller pipe than the one they've
got they're fine crack on so but that
would be useful to actually show people
demonstrate to people actually what
they're saying
secondly
independent um and all of that it all
very good if it's not legally enforcable
it's really not worth the money spending
on
it C Bron never go to the V thank you
chair like I start off with politics
through sewage still in it um
so point is I think we should be getting
offw here because as pointed out say
order give the US will run around on
that one but off what are supposed to be
the ones that are regulating monit but
they don't in the years I was on with
water Bo which was at that time the sort
of watch dog for sa water which a govern
got rid of because it was probably too
effective certainly our chairman was
then um we we used to think then off
what what on Earth are they doing
they've got teeth they don't use it
that's the people show ex a quango of
course we know how loaded they are and
this of what is loaded but we need to
get him here to say what are you doing
about the spills in our rivers and seas
thank you perhaps councelor Christie
will take that on as a bit of a mission
for further work so it's been proposed
I've second can I show in support of
this motion
please you Anonymous no no
against and
abstentions one thank you
[Music]
right the second no motion is counc
L um I raised this kind this topic
slightly um before a question I'm new to
it and I don't know how it all works and
I'm new to an iPad so I can't make thing
bigger um but hopefully everybody's read
this um and it's regarding the car
parking charg in
um the charity fundraising events on the
keing at bford um when I'm suggesting
that those charges um be looked at that
the um that when I asked the question I
was told that it's you know that's the
way it's always worked but I don't think
that's a really good reason to carry
carry on doing good
um just because something's been
happening for some years doesn't seem to
be a good enough reason to carry on
doing it um I firmly believe that the
financial gains to the town of those
these charitable events
um a considerable and more benefit to
the council than than than the car
parking of the money that they'd raised
on the key itself um I firmly believe
that the
increase in bord and parking on a Sunday
or Saturday whichever day it is um in
the other car pars Market the long St
one
um Kingsley the other eay card parks
around the town um the roads and the
High Street and all the rest of it um
the takings there are increased when
events like these take place and that
more than compensates for the loss of
paring on a normal Sunday when no events
are taking place I think the good that
these charitable events are doing the
funds that they raise for these good
causes um yeah I think it's very
important and I think it's something
that we should
really really consider as a benefit to
the community and to the town it's a
benefit to the trailers
um in bhood themselves it brings people
in a lot of the Charities that are doing
these fundraising things they're
providing services that the council is
probably struggling to afford to
provide um I just think it would be and
and if everybody says no no no we can't
possibly do that par car parking chares
is far too important we need every penny
that we can get then I would suggest
that rather than charge the car parking
out at the highest possible rate than
the car parking is um fact that the
cheapest possible rate of the day rather
than the most expensive and so
that thank you that I totally agree with
the second what you said and I'd like to
second that um if it goes through
tonight obviously it'll be referred to
the budget working group I would imagine
because obviously there's a financial
implication here so you've had the
notice motion it's been
seconded you want to speak on I I was
just going to ask is there a considered
view from bford Town Council because I
would have thought that an agreed view
counil chrisy rather
independent
you strangely enough this came up last
Thursday and I can assure you it was
unanimously passed I said I did point
out that uh we get two free days a year
from Tage for car Parks which we use
we also rehire the bridge street car
park on one day year and I pointed out
even bord Town Council was being charged
as though every space was full up all
through the day and so our town Clark is
writing I don't know if the letters
arrive yet um asking about this and
challenging it so it was unanimous said
by councelor Bush can ass you as well
thank that yes uh thank you chair um I
do understand the fent behind councelor
L's uh motion um a question I had this
is probably relevant to other areas in
colage and and the Chang the rules will
actually affect all car pars I assume
not just about Key Street
um it's a subject has come up in H with
me um I am aware that we get two days I
think um and thans um which perhaps does
make some allowance for events which are
of high importance in an area um and I
have
some
concerns that if we're too medient then
it could be open to
abuse um for an example we have a an
event in Hosley which is a mixture of
strong tradition and some faction but
also a private company who who are
probably there partly for um commercial
gang so I think it's not quite as
straightforward subject it may seem if
you pull out individual events and
charity based events I think the um
disappointment last year in hosby was
perhaps because the charges although
correct you um and set in stone the
charges were possibly and I might be
wrong on this um the maximum that could
have been charged for that day and if
there are the data is there to perhaps
provide an average of the income for a
particular Day in the year that would
perhaps be a fair start in a CH
policy didn't agree with did someone for
the hand
up thank you chair I think the exactly
the same thing applies to great
torington we had the same uh when the
fair came into barley Grove they were
been charged as if every space would
been used all day every day for the
duration and that is not the case uh the
amount of money that the fair generates
to to our town they're very generous
they always give us a hand out they give
us charitable money we would hate to
lose them but they were very upset this
year because the the rates have gone up
considerably more than if they were just
being charged on a pro router so it
wasn't even um from from the the manager
of there was was telling me so I I I
really do support this this this whole
proposal okay well
Cy thank you want the wholeheartedly uh
support this this motion I think it's
important to recognize it does affect
all car Parks across the whole of
courage and there is obviously a
difference between for-profit events and
for charitable events and it strikes me
as utterly gross that the district
council is a attempting to profit out of
charity events by charging them for the
entire parking spaces other than the
number of spaces they would normally get
revenue from as councelor LEL has quite
hly pointed out there is a lot of
additional Revenue coming in other car
Parks because if one people still park
somewhere else and not by and large that
is other TSH car Parks so I think we
need to not only look at charging
Charities no more than the a
occupancy of the car park but look at
how much extra Revenue comes into
District Council car parks on those
events and allow that to reduce the
charge even further because that is
essentially just putting torage back
into the same position as if there was
no event it's not making torage District
take a profit out of people who are
volunteering their time and giving their
their money to approve of charity and
social
activities
um for the good of the entire community
and I think we shouldn't be profiting
out of that perfect timing five minutes
up there okay five minutes are up right
unless you do it very very quickly then
thank you chair uh just want a
clarification from officers would this
notice and motion be applying to all car
pars or just the Billy key one that's me
in the motion just the one just the b
key one that's all that's up for grabs
at the that's all that's been discussed
right it's been proposed by counc I
secondary show hands in
support bearing in mind this will go to
the budget working group presumably to
be discussed
further
against and extensions
okay the next clearly car the next no
motion is K craigy to present the
motion thank you very much for the
opportunity to present this motion um
obviously I think it's important to
separate the two elements of the motion
which is about the fford and torage
Heritage Harbor uh representing about 20
Heritage groups now along the
esur that are come together to work
together to improve the offering of
torage and um enable us as a an area to
make more of our resource in Heritage uh
we know that Heritage tourism is the
most stable and robust form of Tourism
we know also it generates the most most
income of any type of Tourism and is
least seasonally effective
so that type of Tourism is something
that we really must support and I think
the first part of this motion is really
about recognizing the important and
hardworking effort of those groups to
come together and and establish uh a
group of workings which will hopefully
work well with the Regeneration boards
both in bford and in great ton because
of course the title part of torch wrot
and spr appor in the north all the way
down to Great TT and because of the r
Canal even to the south of rosemore the
royal he Gardens there so actually the
three largest conations in torage all
have elements within the torage and in
fact obviously this council is named off
to that River because of the significant
importance that it has has over the many
years and also in the second part really
is about addressing the fact that we as
a counil obviously do have to come up
with our place story as they they call
it now in the the leveling up
partnership the place story is about us
providing the data the the information
about what makes courage unique what
makes our challenges unique what what we
would like to see and what our vision is
and there is no better group placed to
provide the
information for for the officers and in
fact do a large amount of the work the
officers wouldn't be able to do in in
deep guiding in many Heritage aspects
along the river and so in fact getting
these voluntary and charity group on
board is about saving the officers time
and about essentially getting better
value for money than hiring a consultant
because quite frankly there is no
Consultants out there that will have the
depth of knowledge that our heritage
organizations uh presently possess and
so I think it's really important that
whatever this place place story includes
if if the elements of Heritage that we
get the heritage groups to provide that
information and really beef up what is a
unique place
and so I hope you support us thank
you right do got to go into debate on
this coun councelor Smith first
all um I'm not sure if I should declare
an interest because I'm chair of the T
Valley Railway but I I thoroughly
support this whole thing I love the idea
of deep di in the river I'm not sure how
water
quality would would be affected by that
but no I I I think this is such an
important thing for our our area so I
would hold out of
this Annie Bron I'd like to as you
second it counc I'd like to Second this
motion I I think that everything that
Council C says is so true we don't take
enough advantage of our Ruba in the best
possible way and that is not to exploit
it but to celebrate it and to use it to
help regenerate Our Town particularly
bord it needs regeneration it's becoming
derit business are withdrawing and we
have this valuable asset our wonderful
river that needs to be uh celebrated and
used more to make sure the fford remains
a beautiful town and attracts people for
Heritage tourism among others I think
this is a splendid notice of motion and
I second
it I thought coun Smith was doing that I
see I thought I had did did actually say
second you said
supportor Christie just just a simple
question I mean I support it but we
heard from start to start in Ken
James does it does this actually fit
with the leveling up so far because it
seems to be a
project is does it fit with what you
said because as I understood it you said
that we're still in you know the first
steps they
is it
AE James an answer to your question we
don't know and the only issue I would
have and I spoke to counc craigy about
this I'm quite happy to look at funding
to do that what I can't agree to is ring
fing
15,000 of money that goes to the
leveling up fund now if we do that and
it turns out this project doesn't fit
the qu area we've then got 15,000 out of
90 locked up so you are gambling on not
doing the leveling up project because
you've locked up some money already and
that is just not acceptable I'm afraid I
I support everything they said about the
harbor board um or the harbor we have
got to start looking um because the
boats aren't coming in it is an asset
that's got to be looked at and I've got
no problems with that my issue is you
want to lock up 15,000 of the leveling
up fund when we don't know if that
project will fit the criteria yes it' be
helpful to have criteria come forward
but until we know exactly where we're
going you can't lock up money because if
you do and it doesn't qualify and I'm
not saying it does or doesn't what I'm
saying is we have no idea at the moment
but you have locked up money that we
would need and you're putting any other
project at risk so I can't support it in
this present form that you are locking
up 15,000 pound of leveling up fund for
one project that we don't know if it
fits the fits the criteria I'm sorry you
just
can't all I would say James um is that
the four Matrix thing criteria are
already known and the the the way that
this
project or these these suggestion that
fits in with can be I mean I'm surprised
that somebody hasn't from
[Music]
the sorry it's a bit of a m um not but
they could send that that information to
you to show you how that fits in with
the which the for mat dists are already
established that the leveling up
fund projects have to conform to or you
like wellbeing and all the rest of their
the B
Etc fits in because the
wellbeing generated by
the volunteer from the volunteering
sector and and the other um criteria I
mean I'm conscious that you know you
don't go into great details and I
haven't got the great details with me
but it can be shown how they do fit in
with those criteria and those criteria
are already declared for Matrix because
that's part of the it's not all like
nobody knows anything at all about it um
I think you'll agree those form have
already been declared and it could
easily be shown
how what has been
suggested fix so I mean it's not it's
not a about project that wouldn't be
anywhere near the and and sorry and
Jeffrey Cox said that I mean think
Jeffrey Cox said that those that that
what is being proposed and has been
talking to
them that he was very positive that that
is that would
be within the LEL up well I'm sorry just
I can't take any more speakers because
we're have gone way over the five
minutes allocation on this so um it's
being proposed and it's
been I'm sorry we've gone over the five
minute debate
time you want
amend any more debate on I'm
afraid
so
was who
second I'm just asking BR
second in support of C cra's
motion all those
things okay and
again extensions
numbers
[Music]
out want to read them yeah they add up
yes they do chair it's seven for 15
against and eight abstentions thank
you okay the last notice a motion this
evening is for from P
BR thank you J well you have before you
cancel the the no motion there with the
the bullet points I've made uh start the
first one the remoteness of this place I
mean if you don't drive a car you ain't
coming here are you especially if you're
a low income or a pensioner who who
doesn't have a vehicle it's this this is
not a user friendly site at all um the
Acoustics are poor you know some of the
counselors I struggle to here she's a
great pity because they what much say is
all right for me I've got a big mouth a
big noise that comes out of it and and
and that may think well that's an asset
no it ain't because back a few years ago
I was reported to Standards Board for
forceful delivery in the council chamber
yes see when when did standard Bo you
know as I said to you before I've been
there many a time well that was one of
the more stupid things that was leveled
against me but you can't argue with that
um
and of course there there's no
microphones here here earlier on uh
they're not arriving either so we're
going to have this situation where some
counselors can be heard and others can't
now in a democracy I think that every
person's voice equals and they therefore
you should all hear the argument no
matter who you are whether you're soft
spoken or loud spoken you know that that
the Democratic process and of course
there's blind spots you know over there
yeah
councel McKenzie sat over there he can't
see some of the councils over here
doesn't know who's there speaking and
that's a very important point I think
when we're having debates that members
of the public should be able to see
which council is saying what and you
could do that in town hall no hiding way
down there we can see who's doing the
speaking and we should go back to the
town hall on that reason alone nothing
else uh limmited seating for the public
we got some seating because we don't get
many public up here now but you know
over the years
counselors lot of years of that actually
some of the most significant decisions
taken by this Council were made because
right decisions at is because the public
were present in numbers I'll give you a
couple of examples Long divisia Walk car
park which is a very pleasant car park I
think you'll agree quite well laid out
and landscaped and then fall out the sky
I came because torage was in the process
bit like Plymouth many well it wasn't
many years ago they went in with
chainsaws early in the morning and and
were stopped and they couldn't cut them
trees they wanted to you know we had
over a thousand people from lond Hill
car par to the town hall because they
were so incensed about what was
happening the people were in the Town
Hall in their numbers and the councilors
obviously made the right decision we had
had things like torington rendering
plant which was being licensed by torich
time and time again they melted down the
render stuff that they were producing
out there and it was a people of
torington who came in and actually you
made sure that the council did the right
decision and refused their license H
with the swimming pool wasn't very
popular that wasn't going to get done
was it h when the people turned up and
made sure that the councilors made the
right decision in a democracy the people
matter they pay their rates and they
want their elected representatives to
make the right decision they can't do it
if they ain't there or can't get there
very easily the town hall is a it's got
the gravitas of democracy and we should
go back to the town halls good enough
for planning and various other
committies what's wrong with it for
councel there various objections before
I mean do you mean to tell me that over
decad
that the council couldn't operate
because the town hall was not very good
of course there's nothing wrong with it
at all it's far better place in this
place so I ask you to support this new's
motion thank you thank you
[Music]
counc
c yeah I'd like to Second councelor Bron
oh pleas notice of motion
uh I I realize apparently there are
problems with the town or with the
electrics in there but this is awful be
a full council meeting for the reasons
that councelor Brent was stated and if
we're not going to have a proper sound
system in here because this these
microphones and this system are pathetic
people on on YouTube can't hear properly
what's being said at all but the town
always we've had 36 counselors in there
over the years no problem it's a bit of
a squeeze sometimes and it was being
reviewed how it could be set out and
there is room for the 36 counselors if
they all do turn up at once which didn't
happen very often and offices as well
and and it's worked very well there's
plenty of seating for the public not
very comforable and
also and it's accessible there a bus
service from all over the district into
bipo it it should be in there we should
have it in there and whatever the issues
are currently with the town hall the
sooner they're rectified and the four
Council goes back to that and the
Committees the better thanks
sh M new yeah um I'm afraid I can't
support council's um view uh I would ask
when he made reference to a large number
of people from holworthy coming to
petition for uh their swimming pool uh
which was held I wonder how many came on
the
bus um seating part of our seating
nowadays they're out there now on
YouTube buses to the rural areas your
comment there was a very bider Centric
comment this is a district council and
most of the people in this District do
not live in this town or indeed nor of
them next door I also think it's
important this could be improved
acoustically or microphones but it's
modern it looks apart it's fit for
purpose it's also important that we are
seen not to be purely an extension of
bidford Town Council and actually
locationally I think we benefit from
being in a separate place that's nothing
against bit of a Town Council but it's
important that we are seen to be
separate from a separate organization
thank you
chair
okay Mr Brenton's motion has been
proposed has been seconded a show van
all in favor
please and
against
an
exstension read chair that's 12 for 17
against and one out okay motion is
clearly lost okay that brings us to the
end of the meeting at four minutes
minutes minutes too
late
um anybody has oh yes
yes second
please